question three was very poorly done now
you know that already okay
but the disappointing thing is that it
was poorly done because I think you
looked at it and freaked out because
you'd never seen a question quite
phrased like this before okay now I'll
admit you know it is a little more scary
whoa whose could all that where did that
a in that pot and all that coming
something come from so that's why a lot
he just looked at it and just abandon it
okay
however can I just suggest I think it's
these kinds of questions specifically
that really tell you how much you
understand is what I mean okay when you
get a question that is exactly how you
seen before like 1a 1a okay that's more
or less exactly what you've seen before
and you just go through steps right when
you get a mark for that or you don't get
a mark for that all that tells you is
okay did I did I you know get the
algorithm right and was I able to
execute it
that's all didn't really actually show
any understanding so much if you know
the steps you don't necessarily need to
know what partial fractions are or why
they work or why they're useful in order
to do 1a right when you get to question
3 when it's phrased differently in order
to do this question well and as you see
when I go through this I would
continually
ask this question it's all of that do
you understand what each of these things
means do you know what it means is
something is an increasing function you
like of course I do
well maybe you did it if you struggled
to transition from Part B to Part C
right do you understand how two
inequalities work of course I do
well maybe you did it if you couldn't
transition from C part one to C part two
right those kinds of things
so these questions are really valuable
to you is ends really weird but you
ought to cherish them because they tell
you exactly what you need to work on
right it tells you the concepts where
you need to go back and not just be able
to say okay I can do these questions but
do I get this can I explain this to
someone else now because I know I know
what this means and I know what approach
I would take even though I've never seen
this kind of question before does that
make sense so question three is a real
gem so pay
attention when we're going through this
maybe on your own when you're working
you might want to follow me live my life
for this one because we all did it so
badly okay here's where I'll do
something that I hope will model rightly
the way that you watch our purchase you
do what I looked and I had a I had a
freak to Marx and I thought okay how do
I feel about this as a teacher right as
your teacher the person who prepared you
allegedly for this exam okay and I word
I won't lie in some places I was quite
disappointed okay
but if you're anything like me I think
most of us we'd like to think ah this
isn't my fault I wasn't prepared for
this someone else someone else is to
blame from my lousy mark or you know
suppose I had too many assessments on or
is because whatever right you think of a
reason and they say that's the reason
why I didn't do well in this exam now I
can do the same I can say ah those lousy
students they never pay attention to me
blah blah right I think that's the wrong
thing to do most of the time and I
question to myself I thought when I
looked particularly at a pate or this
question which arguably was the easiest
part of this question much got the four
marks all of them but you got it by the
skin of your teeth
it was dreadfully set out and I thought
to myself okay maybe I have not modelled
for this for you well okay I want you to
all have a look at the cretians paper
right now would you hold it up just sort
of hold it around so people can sort of
see it under the size of the room okay
now you have a look at who shines page
and compare it to yours okay if you're
working was all over the place it took
me probably twice as long to market and
go through it then it stood out maybe
you don't mind that it took me twice as
long and you shouldn't have to but it's
in your interest as a person who's
trying to communicate things
mathematically to put them out clearly
from start to finish not from start - Oh
some things are here and then oh I don't
need to do a few more things over here
and then sort of swap sides and it's a
bit of a nightmare okay so later on if
you didn't get a close look at it do
take a look at three chances
because it's an exempt our right but
I'll try and work through it on the
board now he's what we had to prove this
now this is what she had to do and you
were you were confined into a method
because they said use the t method okay
fine
so therefore you've got to start off by
saying let and then you have to do all
of these things okay now this is where
some of your problems began because you
either did this somewhere completely
different right which might have been
okay binding at least five or six cases
you've got this next line like just the
substitution you've got that wrong right
the problem was you knew where you were
meant to end up so you started from a
wrong sort of setup and somehow you made
your way to the right thing and if I've
written fudge on your arm on your
solution what that means is it's kind of
like just I'll just make this negative a
plus cuz I know it needs to be or
something like that okay so you have to
start off like this I'm gonna do this
exhaustively okay you must start off
like this by far the most problems crept
in by far if you've got this part wrong
most of the poms crept in here which is
not surprising because you've been using
T results for a while in these terms but
this is a bit new because we've only as
extension to students have you been
using it for integration okay so a small
number of you got this wrong and then it
just fell apart from there okay the
first mark was not for doing that the
first mark for is actually putting all
of that in to keep correctly okay so I'd
say this there are huge amounts of
simplification you could do okay but
because this was a proof I have all the
hallmarks on it right you could not skip
steps you could not skip steps and there
were some crucial steps that got skills
all right what I would do here is I
would multiply across right and you
would get this this was about oh sorry
even that's wrong that was another place
that areas Christian forgot to do your
honor
because it's just a normal substitution
you forgot your boundaries
and it suddenly prize disappeared those
kinds of things what I mean my budget
okay uh this was this was the furthest
that I accepted you simplify if you
skipped any more than that right and
centered on magic at the end I have the
result I needed you didn't demonstrate
that you knew how to simplify to results
from an integral so that comes down to
here now the reason why I actually wrote
this line up for you is because so many
of you went wrong from here to the next
line what happened you should have
written this and then your twos would
cancel right but so many of you you miss
the T squared or you missed a T like you
just didn't collect like terms properly
collecting like terms what was that yes
your ace I think is when you start doing
into season like this right and so I
guess this is this is a lesson for you
in terms of coming back to check things
and you can't go back to check things if
the working is not there okay
so you get to there and then you realize
okay I need to split this thing up right
so then you put your partial fractions
okay now I think the partial fractions
were generally done pretty well and pi
that is because it's a simple partial
fraction to divide so that was lucky for
you excuse me okay now at this point you
get your logs I might use this as a
point to mention I know lots of people
do it but I am really not a fan of this
not a fan okay and I saw it all over the
place
again I mean it was an integration right
so no surprise okay I'll tell you why I
dislike it um it's interesting because
the the most common people who do it are
people who know extension to their the
people who like you know these extra
square bits on the brackets who's got
time to right voters I just want to go
here right
I don't bother myself with trivial
things like that I know what this means
except the irony is the place where
these screws people up the most is
integration by parts which only
extension to students know I'll tell you
why because it's in integration of my
parts that's the most common place where
you get definite integrals mixing with
other stuff right you know you've got
your other right now you have a look at
this how much of this does this definite
integral you know substitute values in
how much does it apply to me and the
answer is well it should be all of it
right now if you did that you're not
saving any time with this actually oh
people who want to save time you're
writing a whole extra long line whoa
point two of a second but most of you
did not you read this right which is
wrong it's wrong that's equal to I mean
if we if I continue this game right
that's equal to this which is not okay
people want to save time what are you
saving really and what are you losing I
think you're losing a lot more than
you're saying so that's just I mean I
know people are going to cling to it to
the bitter end but just don't say I
didn't warn you okay now you get to this
point you need to do some simplification
of the logs right you cannot go from
here to this result you can't do it and
lots of you and maybe you were running
out of time like I can't be bothered to
do that and you said I'm from there you
wrote down your result and you couldn't
do it okay so I was expecting you to do
at least something like this okay let's
do our first line
there you go okay so you've got a
reckoning with the fact that you've got
things that are zero right and then
you've got these um these negatives
which are going to become powers right
after you work with those that's how you
could get down to your final result okay
so let me tell you where the four marks
were because I didn't mention it before
number one for this line for actually
taking all your T results and
substituting the whole thing okay some
of you got confused because you did it
in bits and pieces you did some of your
feeders in some of your T's over like
two or three lines bad idea one mark
here second mark for getting to this
point for taking integrate and actually
taking the effort to simplify it
properly okay third bark for actually
integrating and then the fourth mark was
here in the logs okay hmm
by the way just as a point of interest
the reason why you don't you really need
to worry about absolute values here is
because you know what the young you know
what those values are so you don't need
to say oh absolutely of that because it
is positive right in a similar way to X
square plus one being positive before so
in case you're wondering why I haven't
put any of those in